[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a short drama film
called the boy with a camera for a face
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
at the beginning of the movie we are
shown a broken tv the camera zooms into
it and leads us to the day the
protagonist is born the doctors and
nurses surround his mother urging her to
push harder while the father sits at the
other side with a camera he believes
that he is going to capture a beautiful
moment but what happens next makes him
put the camera away in confusion even
the nurses and the doctor share the same
look of confusion as they pass the
newborn baby around when the mother gets
to hold her baby she doesn't know what
to think of it because the newborn has a
camera for a face
he involuntarily records the birth from
the other side as a normal camera would
the doctors go crazy trying to figure
out how this is possible they stare at
the sonogram for hours but do not seem
to find the reason for the baby not
having a face they try to pass it up as
genetics but no camera genes are found
in the parents with time they get
frustrated and start blaming the mother
for sleeping with a camera the husband
accuses his wife of cheating honey i
know that the new iphone is sexy but
why'd you have to do it she is left
alone with her child and doesn't know if
she can ever love him as a human if he
becomes the reason for their divorce but
her worries fade away when the doctors
claim he is in fact the husband's kid
they also admit that they do not know
the cause behind his head being a camera
but they have found out that to keep the
child alive they should put a blank tape
in the slot on his back it must be done
every night without fail to prevent
heart failure the blank tapes mean that
the kid is bound to record every moment
of his life even if he doesn't want to
the doctor inserts the day one tape into
his back and sends the camera boy home
with his parents by now the parents have
accepted him as he is because no matter
the face he will always be their child
as the camera boy grows older he starts
to take pictures on command one day when
trying to take a family photo the
parents cannot seem to get good lighting
hence they hold the object camera and
make their son click pictures they have
finally found a use for him that only he
is good at every night they would change
the boy's tape and put it in the
cupboard safely at first they are
delighted that because of the tapes he
will remember every moment in his life
but what the parents fail to register is
that a lifetime's worth of tapes
requires a lifetime to watch the
cupboard soon starts to fill up with
tapes and memories that are of no use to
him soon the camera boy grows old enough
to go to school even though he has no
expression on his face we can tell he is
nervous everyone looks at him
differently for obvious reasons the kids
start to bully him pushing him around
calling him camera head and telling him
he should be dead but they forget that
the boy's memory is photographic when
his mother sees the tape at the end of
the day she fumes in anger she visits
the principal's office the very next day
and shows him the video with clear
evidence the bullies have no way to
defend themselves they are punished for
their actions and starting that day they
stop bothering the camera boy however
they move on to bullying another kid
calling him fat and telling him to kill
himself the camera boy watches them in
fear unknowingly recording them the tape
yet again makes it to the principal's
office and the bullies are taught a
lesson as time goes by and the camera
boy learns to socialize he makes a lot
of friends his uniqueness attracts
people towards him but with the
attention also comes drawbacks his
friends even the closest ones often
treat him like he is only a camera
soon like any normal teenager the camera
boy falls in love with a beautiful girl
they go on dinner dates talk about
different things and seem to get along
well until one day when they are in bed
and things start to get steamy the
camera boy tries undressing her but she
suddenly realizes that he is filming
everything she pushes him away calling
him a pervert for something he has no
control over the boy offers to put a
lens cap on but the girl asks him to get
out of her room she never talks to him
again leaving him heartbroken he starts
to think that he will never find true
love because of his face
starting that day his life goes downhill
he has never let inside a movie hall
because of the no camera policy moreover
his father throws the house tv away
because the boy watching it would be
considered piracy he gets depressed and
refuses to go outside but even at home
he has nothing to do he starts to get
bored and lonely cursing his fate for
making him unique
that is until one day when his life
changes while walking down a road he
comes across a girl weirdly enough her
face is unfocused from his point of view
he tries moving his lenses in different
positions but cannot seem to see her
features he doesn't know the reason for
the weird phenomenon but it doesn't
bother him the girl becomes his friend
and with time they fall in love since he
cannot see her face she doesn't mind
getting naked in front of him it is
almost as if god sensed he was depressed
and sent her just for him the two have
been dating for quite some time when one
day a man approaches them he turns out
to be a producer who wants to make a
show out of the camera boy's life he
wants the boy to hand in all of the
tapes that he has filmed until now so
they can create a several episode show
with less budget handing in all the
tapes means that they should give up the
tapes of them making love the couple is
reluctant at first but they agree to be
a part of it when given a briefcase full
of money the show hits the air and
instantly becomes a success the couple
gains millions of fans in only a few
days they turn into celebrities and are
swarmed by paparazzi everywhere they go
with the money they buy a brand new
house together as the show's popularity
increases the camera boy is given his
own channel where people would have to
pay to see his life on live television
he soon asks his girlfriend to be his
wife that part of their life is also
broadcast live to the world they have no
privacy at all but it is the least of
their concerns because the show's
ratings skyrocket after he proposes to
her they get married as the world
watches happy for the couple then
something that had never crossed the
camera boy's mind happens people become
addicted to his show
so much so that the entire nation stays
indoors watching his life 24 7. it is
almost as if he is the only living
person and all others are living life
through him when he and his wife get
bored of such a lonely life they return
to his childhood home as soon as he
opens the door the piles of tapes of his
life come into his view the house barely
has any space for furniture because of
all the tapes the boy goes to the first
closet of tapes and stares at them
reminiscing about his childhood and
thinking of how far he has come then he
goes to the living room to see that his
wife is in front of the tv she like the
others has been addicted to watching the
show he tries to switch the tv off but
nothing happens he calls the wife trying
to wake her up but she remains staring
at the television the boy sheds a single
tear and finally realizes that the only
way to wake up the entire country is to
stop live streaming the show so he
brings out the first tape of his life
that was ever recorded he plays the tape
on tv while in the bathtub people who
are watching the live stream also get to
witness his birth through the video
everyone holds their breath as the boy
puts the tv into the tub electrocuting
himself he dies while watching the video
of his own birth the live show finally
ends with his death and people register
how obsessed they had become they go out
and enjoy their lives like they did
before the show his wife is at a park
heartbroken by his death yet she is
happy that people including herself have
come back to their senses the movie ends
as she watches a man and his kids
playing in the park and taking a picture
together the camera reminds her of her
late husband subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching